mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
ich begrüße sie zu einem kultur platz
der ganz im zeichen der bedenklichen
ereignisse der vergangenen tage steht
die bilder und nachrichten die uns hier
auf unserer redaktion erreichen lassen
erschaudern
so auch die erste geschichte aus der
ukraine die wir ihnen heute erzählen
werden
[Musik]
der freie journalist roman shell war
noch vor dem russischen zaren angriff
für uns in die ukraine gereist er wollte
an der ursprünglichen frontlinie im dom
bass ein psychologenteam dabei begleiten
wie es kriegstraumatisierte kinder und
jugendliche betreut doch dann
überschlugen sich die ereignisse und die
geplante reportage nahm eine dramatische
wende
vor einer woche
katharina schulte loh war auf dem weg in
die ost ukraine
dort therapiert sie seit jahren kinder
und jugendliche
die gewalt in der krisenregion
eskalierte erneut die psychologin weiß
dass sie gebraucht wird
sollte es etwas ruhiger werden so werden
wir zuerst mit kleinen kindern die so
genannte kunsttherapie machen und dann
sind die jugendlichen dran mit einer
körpertherapie
außerdem wollen wir uns mit ihnen länger
unterhalten
bilder aus dem letzten herbst seit dem
ausbruch des konfliktes 2014 kümmert
sich das team um die fern kinder und
veranstaltet feste die einzigen
kulturveranstaltungen in der
krisenregion die kleinen haben kaum
positive erlebnisse und noch schwache
erinnerungen an ein leben in frieden
in diesem großen wohnblocks ihr leben
höchstens 34 personen voraus
die meisten wohnungen stehen leer das
leben eines kindes hier ist sehr traurig
und eintönig denn diese ortschaften
sterben aus
der krieg gehört im donbass schon seit
langem zum alltag eine marissa granate
schlug ein am hellichten tag das dorf
groupies granada front steht seit wochen
unter beschuss dutzende kinder leben
hier sie müssen mit erwachsenen in
kellern hausen
ja das ist schrecklich ich habe letzte
nacht auch nicht geschlafen ich habe
dasselbe gehört wie du die explosionen
machen schon angst und das ist ok angst
zu haben
katharina ist ernsthaft besorgt um die
sicherheit und den psychischen zustand
der kinder in worbis k die psychologin
versammelt sie mit ihnen in den dorfclub
zu gehen für eine kurz therapie
das gebäude ist eines der sichersten ihr
denn es hat einen beton keller
zuerst sollen die kinder erzählen wie es
ihnen geht
[Musik]
bisher
das team bringt alle kinder nach hause
bevor es dunkel wird dann am abend
beginnen in der regel besonders schwere
kämpfe
mein ziel war den schockzustand bei den
kindern zu beenden
leider wurde die therapie unterbrochen
wegen eines beschusses
im keller habe ich versucht mit ihnen
weiter zu arbeiten ein interessantes
phänomen sie alle zeigen sich
kämpferisch aber sobald es kracht
verstecken sie sich ganz schnell
am nächsten tag schwere kämpfe rings um
die aktivistinnen verteilen im eiltempo
hilfsgüter in unterschiedlichen
ortschaften überall zerstörung
auch worbis cars steht weiter unter
heftigen beschuss die kinder flehen das
psychologinnen thiemann sie raus zu
bringen es wird entschieden sie zu
evakuieren hauptsache weg die eltern
allerdings bleiben
inzwischen ist klar die russische armee
hat mit dem einmarsch begonnen
zehntausende menschen sind auf der
flucht richtung westen
meine eltern sind jetzt im dorf warum
bisky und über ihren köpfen fliegen
geschossen das ist so schrecklich meiner
mutter macht sich große sorgen sie sagt
bald werden wir wohl an der russischen
grenze leben
das psychologenteam bringt die kinder in
die west ukraine für 1000 kilometer
brauchen sie vier volle tage durch staus
und immer neue check points
nach der zermürbenden fahrt und drei
übernachtungen in kalten hotels ist die
gruppe in den karpaten nahe der grenze
zur eu angekommen
hier können sie für einen monat in einem
hostel wohnen
spitzt sich die lage auch im westen des
landes weiter zu bleibt nur die
evakuieren der kinder in die eu
einstweilen sind sie in sicherheit
katharina schulter jova steht dagegen
schon vor der nächsten aufgabe die
eltern und großeltern der jugendlichen
aus der inzwischen zerbombten stadt
aktiv zu retten
[Musik]
hunderttausende zivilisten versuchten in
den vergangenen tagen aus der ukraine zu
entkommen es ist ein wettlauf gegen die
zeit vertrieben aus der demokratischen
heimat auf der flucht vor der russischen
armee
vergangenen donnerstag putin lässt die
ukraine angriffen droht allen die ihn
stoppen wollen ein paar stunden später
sprechen wir mit einer
literaturwissenschaftlerin im westen der
ukraine
man hat einfach mit einem menschen
das klingt jetzt nicht politisch korrekt
aber ich glaube es ist auch keine zeit
für die politische korrektheit
eine schriftstellerin moskau kurz nach
beginn des angriffs
das ist einfach widerlich ich bin ein
kriegskind
ich gehöre zu der generation die damit
gerechnet hatte zu sterben oder nochmal
einen krieg zu erleben
ein deutscher historiker und russland
kenner ich war
vieles fast alles vorbereitet
das nicht so ganz
putin will die ordnung der welt wie wir
sie kennen zerstören in der ukraine
fürchten die menschen um ihr leben
ich habe sehr große angst um mein kind
ich habe versucht mich von der politik
fern zu halten und jetzt kann ich gar
nicht erklären was gerade geschieht
außer dass es eine absolute
gesetzlosigkeit ist
ein bruch des völkerrechts einbruch mit
den regeln von dialog und kompromiss die
uns so selbstverständlich schienen was
treibt diesen mann der glaube an eine
historische mission sagt der russland
kenner gerd koenen für putin ist die
russische geschichte von dunkle reich
alle die dem widersprechen hatte
ausgeschaltet
es ist ein kultureller bruch der
eintritten soll auch der erwünscht ist
wo es unter strafe gestellt wird im
grunde fragen über die russische
geschichte zu stellen die man stellten
muss um sie überhaupt zu verstehen ja
und jetzt ist der präsident der oberste
historikers landes einer der die
geschichte brutal umschreiben will die
ukraine sei gar kein staat könne nur
teil eines großen russland sein der wir
heute den imperator spiel begann als
blasser unbekannter
dann hat er sehr früh angefangen das zu
erkennen dass er jetzt derjenige ist auf
den alle gewartet haben ja er sieht sich
als der mann der vorsehung der da ist
diese lücke zu füllen die
lücke klafft zwischen dem alten
großmacht status und dem heutigen gefühl
von minderwertigkeit
deshalb inszenierte punkten in den
letzten jahren einen blockbuster make
great again
für können eine fassade hinter der sich
ein trauma verbirgt
[Musik]
das ende der großen sowjetunion als auch
die ukraine unabhängig wurde
putin sieht darin die größte
geopolitische katastrophe des 20
jahrhunderts da ist der superlativ den
kopf die größte 20 jahrhunderts wichtig
die unabhängigkeit der ukraine ihr
streben richtung westen für putin ein
teil dieser katastrophe denn die ukraine
ist für ihn russisches kern land
er wählt sie zurück als teil eines neuen
alten imperiums
stellen wir uns kurz vor ist nunmehr
würden auch andere staaten die früher
mit medien waren solche ansprüche
geltend machen ich frage mich wo wie
weit geht man zurück
stellen sie sich vor die mongolei wo sie
sich an das große harmonische reich
erinnern stelle sich vor man würde jetzt
das römische reich wieder herstellen
wollen es klingt wie sie wahrscheinlich
absurd für mich auch
dieser mann macht aus der absurdität
wirklichkeit das recht des stärksten
dreistesten skrupellosesten sitte auf
seiner seite kommt er damit durch kurz
nach dem angriff am donnerstag haben wir
ludmilla uli zweier gefragt ob es in
russland proteste geben werde
du musst ich denke nicht weil ihr die
stimmung der bedrückt hyde der apathie
und vor allem der angst herrscht
aber es gibt dann doch demonstrationen
in russischen städten und bis heute mehr
als 6000 festnahmen
dieser angriff hoffte gerd koenen und
donnerstag könnte vielleicht der anfang
von putins ende sein durch wachsenden
druck von außen und von innen politisch
und wirtschaftlich wenn der sinnlose
krieg immer weitergeht mittlerweile
droht putin mit seinen atom
streitkräften doch ob sarah chalke will
in ihrer heimat bleiben so lange es geht
[Musik]
auch der autor dieser bücher hier andrej
kurkow hat zum beispiel greppin
geschrieben auch er wie vor erst in
seiner heimat der ukraine bleiben
eigentlich hatten wir uns zum interview
verabredet noch vor dem russischen
angriff doch sie können sich vorstellen
plötzlich kam alles anders und die
kommunikation wurde es schwierig ich bin
jetzt mit ihm zu einem video call
verabredet ja guten tag herr krug auf
also ich es aus sicherheitsgründen denke
ich frage ich sie jetzt nicht wo sie
genau sind sonst können sie mir das
natürlich sagen wenn das geht ja das ist
okay ich bin in einem mehr oder weniger
ruhigen ort russland fokussiert ist
autobahnen gebiete wie steht es bei
ihnen um die versorgungslage und
medikamente etc ist hauptproblem ist
flüchtlinge es gibt tausende und
tausende von autos mit leute mit kindern
mit familien und sie versuchen weiter
zur grenze fahren ja es gibt ganz viele
wollen theorie die helfen ihnen mit
ersten bitte übernachtungen im jahr
die leute sind sehr menschlich jeder ist
bereit etwas für fluglinien zu tun haben
sie persönlich jetzt bewusst entschieden
zu bleiben oder es ist flucht gar keine
option
bleibe ich
habe das entschieden ja das ist kein
problem ich musste nur meine tochter
zurück nach london zu schicken weil sie
wollte dort umsehen müssen unter sich
hatte geschafft die grenze zu mitte mit
einem bus überqueren ja und jetzt sie
ist unterwegs nach london
momentan nutzen sie die sprache als
schriftsteller in diesem kampf sage ich
mal ich verfolge sie zb auf twitter sie
sind da sehr aktiv ich bin präsident von
pen ukraine das ist eine organisation
die für
menschenrechte kämpfen für freiheit der
presse und wir haben entschieden
sozusagen
informationskrieg teilzunehmen sowie
übersetzen ganz viele notizen ohne
informationen um weiter an ausländische
zeitungen zu schicken und nicht
schreiben artikel und reportagen jahr
ohne telefonieren verschiedene städte
ohne
rausfinden was passiert dort und dann
schreibe diese informationen und schicke
weiter was bekommen sie mit von anderen
kulturschaffenden wie mobilisieren die
in der ukraine aber vielleicht auch in
russland von russland höhere ich nicht
viel es gab zwei briefe offene briefe
gegen den krieg aber sehr wenige
schriftsteller haben diese briefe und
schrieb traum sächliche russische
kulturschaffende unterstützend brötchen
und ich erwarte nicht viel von dieser
seite ja in ukraine aber praktisch alle
kulturschaffenden sind sehr engagierte
sehr beschäftigte als ein treffer von
tore einige schriftsteller sind schon
soldaten auch ganz viele
kulturschaffende sind freiwilligen wie
brüder kapranos die verleger und
schriftsteller in tiefe wir sind jetzt
auf strassen wm kiew mit waffen unter
patroullieren die straßen ja
während sie selber auch bereits
irgendwann in kampfhandlungen
teilzunehmen wenn nötig ist ja
andrej kurkow ganz herzlichen dank dass
sie sich in diesen schwierigen stunden
zeit genommen haben für dieses gespräch
alles alles gute
ich mache mich auf richtung kleinbasel
dort lebt und arbeitet der fotograf
roland schmid seit ausbruch der krise
2014 hat er das russisch ukrainische
grenzgebiet mehrmals besucht menschen
und alltag zwischen den fronten
dokumentiert
[Musik]
sie sind schon so häufige der ukraine
jetzt überschlagen sich die ereignisse
city zieht mit da aufpassen
fotografiert 14 und 5 und risiko in
osteuropa der wand dokumentiere ich habe
schon einige geschichten über folgen von
krieg also wie wir vermitteln dass immer
missbrauch von der zivilbevölkerung
durch politik meine politik dem durch
die leute rücksicht
sie kontakt mit
jetzt kontakt mit mitarbeitern ukraine
also
lokalen geschäften als finden ich frage
sie mal wieder sehr gut und jetzt die
sache dann alles in ordnung und so und
dann den betrete man dort was ich da
erlebt haben dass das erfreut und
verspätung
mit dem mit einer soldatin kontakt um
roma getroffen haben aber dafür so ist
keine infos
der schritt eine höchstzahl gruppen und
hab ich weiß nicht wo er ist und wie es
dann gold
und absolut ghana wo
in front neuere oder sogar zum teil
zwischen der front liegen aber
wir sind wir schaffen sie das das
abdrucken dissident ai widerstandswillen
die moral wo man menschen service
vermittelt bekommen das hat mich
überhaupt nicht überrascht weil ich
glaub ich glaube dass putin etwas völlig
falsch einschätzt und die ukraine die
gewöhnlich freiheit und in einer
demokratie habe die generierte verhalten
gemacht werden wiedersehen der
sowjetunion untermain und
regimes habe und wir wollen das einfach
nimmt die jugend das ist das verstehen
das bild das ich das handy fotografiert
im kulturhaus in auf tiefe und auf die
wichtige industrie statt wo die rektoren
der frontlinie liegt und in dem
kulturzentrum den siegtreffer um meine
frau gibt vergast sein und einen boxclub
und das ist für sie sehr wichtig einfach
umsetzt treffen unter alltags vergessen
und wenn man dann muss der kultur husak
und dann hörten wir schüsse und die
frontlinien also stattlich ist so real
estate eigentlich sie hat ja mal der
schriftsteller andrej kurkow prof und
fotografiert sie ist durch graue bienen
hexe zu den preis eigentlich ins spiel
dass ich das kann für den inspirations
sie für sie der ganze konflikt wird der
markt das ist schon mal wozu schritt der
frontlinie im
dfbnet züchtet und irgendwo wir probiert
zu überleben das ist genau der mal bin
ich mir das eigentlich ein buch
vorgestellt haben und eltersdorf und axa
tarif gott das genau meine vorstellungen
entsprochen wenn ich das eigentlich
durch lektüre vor dem burgweg
visualisiert kochen
was ich gemacht euch bei qvc
foto frontlinie zu tragen diese dienste
bild kommt rein gefühlsmäßig ist das abi
zu sehen möchtest deine falco wir
eigentlich sowieso nie existiert hat
also ich hab im kissinger gedruckt die
steht nix sie
und der mitarbeiter mit der möchte der
der ukraine derzeit also verschwindet
immer noch liegt also wenn man
politisch anderem eine geschickt und es
wird aggression nicht öffentliches oder
wählte landete
probiere immer beide seiten das gesicht
ein foto vor und probiere ich wenn es
möglich ist einfach zum beiden
sicherheitsleute oder was was wir jetzt
die politik da stellte bucher dass er
nicht
es ist beachtlich erst gerade feierte
spielfilm klondike der ukrainischen
regisseurin marina ihr gorbach auf dem
sundance film festival weltpremiere und
wurde vor rund zwei wochen auch auf der
berlinale gezeigt jetzt quasi eingeholt
von der aktualität passierte erst recht
zum film der stunde ein beeindruckendes
familiendrama zwischen alltäglichen
nöten eskalation und stagnation
der turm der berliner gedächtniskirche
erinnert bis heute daran dass der wunsch
nach einem geregelten leben keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist schon gar
nicht wenn krieg herrscht
noch bevor putin die muskeln spielen
ließ und russische soldaten die ukraine
überfielen war marina r gorbach nach
berlin gekommen und vom anfang des
ukraine konflikt zu erzählen aus
ukrainischer perspektive
wir nehmen die zuschauer mit hinter die
kulissen der ereignisse die sich in
meiner heimat abspiele
ich habe selbst aus einer kleinen stadt
nahe an der russischen grenze natürlich
mache ich mir große große sorgen
oxana china spielt er die hauptrolle in
klondike
ilka ist hochschwanger aber sie denkt
nicht daran ins krankenhaus zu gehen das
risiko einer hausgeburt wird nicht
kleiner wenn das haus im donbass steht
und pro-russische separatisten
versehentlich die wohnzimmerwand
weggeschossen haben
[Musik]
das ist ein film über weibliche
überlebensinstinkt und die kunst des
widerstands
klondike erzählt vom wunsch nach einem
geregelten leben an einem ort wo alle
regeln ihre gültigkeit verloren haben an
western von der östlichen grenze europas
im sommer 2014 fährt schweres gerät in
der region jetzt auf ihr kasmann toll
ich sympathisiert mit den chor
russischen separatisten
nach der besetzung der krim tauchen auch
im donbass jene berüchtigten grünen
männchen ohne hoheitszeichen auf die
ihre kasse heimat in ein schlachtfeld
verwandeln
am 17 juli 2014 in meinem geburtstag
waren wir in der ukraine als die malerei
maschine m h 17 abgeschossen wurde
die noch nicht mal soldaten waren das
waren einfache menschen denen man waffen
gegeben hat
wir waren geschockt von dieser tragödie
bis heute hat niemand die verantwortung
übernommen und an unserer grenze
herrscht immer noch krieg
lkw's bruder steht auf seiten der
ukraine ihr mann tallec hält zu den
separatisten die frontlinie verläuft
mitten durch eras familie
der krieg bleibt im film seltsam
distanziert und ist doch immer präsent
ein beständiges hintergrundrauschen dass
sich unterdessen in einem donnergrollen
entladen hat
ich hatte eine seltsame unterhaltung mit
meiner nachbarin sie ist eine alte frau
und hat probleme mit ihren zähnen sie
sagte ich habe wenig geld und zweifle ob
es sich lohnt zum zahnarzt zu gehen wenn
es krieg gibt sind wir in ein paar tagen
tot da sollte ich mein letztes geld
nicht für zähne aus
dieser schwarze humor sagt viel über die
ukraine aus die leute fragen sich
unentwegt ob sie ihr haus reparieren
sollen oder nicht
unsere psychische gesundheit leidet
unter dem nicht enden wollenden kriegs
rauschen
seit 2014 hat dieser konflikt und
nunmehr krieg am rande europas über
14.000 opfer gefordert
wer klondike gesehen hat wird die
grauenhafte entwicklung der letzten tage
besser verstehen
[Musik]
klondike hat bislang noch kein staat
datum in der schweiz dafür läuft hier
derzeit olga der kinofilm um eine junge
kunstturnerin die hin- und hergerissen
ist zwischen ihrer bedrohten
ukrainischen heimat und der sicherheit
als turnerin im schweizer nationalteam
das debüt von regisseur eli grad da auch
für den schweizer filmpreis nominiert
[Musik]
roland schmid sitzen da die idyllische
vom balkon die kraft der neutralen
schweiz wie können sie den tag mit der
diskrepanz und der distanz und es ist
ein vorteil aber nicht worauf sie meinte
stürmer freut sich staub und in zwei
wochen soll das noch zu
und dann roger moore ganze look später
von der ukraine nach unten und damit
auch schön und so in meinem berliner
verein so komische ca was bedeutet es
weg schrieb launig wenn sie so bald wie
möglich auf rund
25 punkte das ist nicht gerade ihren
tricks getümmel stürzen sondern
überlegt mal richtig polenzko mit mit
den flüchtlingen vernichter bis zu
machen sie hat sich selber schminkt
verbracht die krise geführt ganz
grundsätzlich gefragt warum machen sie
die arbeit
sehr gut als ich näher wir einfach und
und
weiterbildung meinen könnte aber aus ich
bin jetzt schon erklärt
wie man gegen wir außerhalb geschützter
nicht vom vor dem ganze es hat jetzt
viele journalisten und
agenturen wo jetzt der aktuelle konflikt
abdecken unterbruchs mich unbedingt dazu
und damit bleibt mir für heute die
verabschiedung und der hinweis auf die
sternstunde philosophie gleich im
anschluss putins welt ein gespräch mit
philosoph und autor michael melka -
nächste woche begrüßt bei kulturplatz
wieder meine kollegin eva wannenmacher
dann zum thema inklusion im
kulturbetrieb die jungs noch bald
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos